veamos si nos podemos imaginar una
figura en tres dimensiones cuya base es
esta región sombreada que tenemos aquí
entre las gráficas de igual a fx y la
gtx así es que esta es la base de la
figura esta región que sombreado aquí
con este color parece púrpura y la
figura como que se sale de la pantalla
aquí esta línea que he dibujado aquí en
azul representa el borde superior de la
figura y si tomamos secciones
transversales de la figura como podría
ser esta que tenemos aquí en amarillo
son secciones transversales a la figura
que son perpendiculares al eje x esas
secciones transversales van a tener
forma de triángulos rectángulos que son
isósceles así es que si nosotros
extraemos una de estas secciones y la
vemos de lado
esta sería la hipotenusa de un triángulo
rectángulo que además es isósceles como
este que tenemos aquí entonces esta
hipotenusa del triángulo la vamos a
ubicar directamente sobre la base de la
figura este es un triángulo isósceles
estos dos lados son iguales y aquí
tenemos el ángulo recto así es que esta
distancia que tenemos aquí entre este
punto y este punto la longitud de la
hipotenusa corresponde a esta distancia
que tenemos aquí entre las gráficas de
fx y gtx para un valor dado de x
obviamente el valor de esa distancia va
a ir variando a medida que cambia el
valor de x y para ayudarnos a visualizar
la figura aquí dibuje el plano
coordenada como si fuera el plano
horizontal para tener una perspectiva
como si estuviéramos viendo la figura
desde arriba con un cierto ángulo así es
que aquí es donde he dibujado la base de
la figura esta región que tenemos aquí
de hecho para que se aprecie mejor voy a
hacer los trazos del sombreado como si
fueran paralelos a las secciones
transversales así es que saque sombreado
en la base pero también tenemos otros
dos lados es este lado que tenemos aquí
que podemos ver como el lado superior o
el lado izquierdo más precisamente que
en esta gráfica corresponde a esta
región de aquí cuando estamos viendo la
figura desde arriba y también tenemos
este otro lado que en esta figura
corresponde al lado derecho mientras que
en esta gráfica se ubica en la región
posterior ahora todo esto que hemos
hecho aquí inclusive este intento de
visualizarlo en tres dimensiones es para
ver si podemos obtener una integral
definida que nos permita calcular el
valor del volumen de nuestra figura que
aquí hemos intentado dibujar en tres
dimensiones y que parece un medio balón
de fútbol americano medio balón de rugby
te invito a que le pongas pausa e
intentes calcular cuál es esa integral
definida que calcula el volumen vas a
necesitar usar el hecho de que las
gráficas
funciones intersectan en el origen y en
el punto d
así es que trata de obtener esa
expresión es integral definida donde van
a aparecer ceros c de fx que de equis y
con la cual vas a poder calcular el
volumen de la figura bien supongo que le
pusiste pausa y lo intentaste hagámoslo
ahora juntos una manera de ver esto es
que el volumen de la figura completa lo
podemos aproximar calculando el volumen
de cada una de estas secciones
transversales o rebanadas cuyas caras
son triangulares y podemos suponer que
tienen un espesor realmente pequeño un
espesor realmente pequeño déjame
sombrear lo aquí en esta figura ya esa
pequeñísima longitud del espesor vamos a
designar la x de x así es que vamos a
calcular el volumen de cada una de estas
rebanadas calculando el área lateral y
multiplicando la por ese pequeño espesor
de x multiplicándolo por ese pequeño de
x que aquí en la figura tridimensional
sería este de aquí
este es de equis déjame escribirlo más
claramente
este aquí sería de equis y ahora como
vamos a calcular entonces el volumen de
cada una de estas rebanadas bien déjame
llamarle a esta longitud h y sabemos que
h está dada por fx menos gdx que aquí
corresponde a esta longitud
así es que esto es h así es que entonces
h es igual déjame de hecho llamarla hdx
pues va a ser una función de x hdx es
igual a efe x - menos de x ahora ya que
tenemos h como calculamos el área de
este triángulo bien sabemos que este es
un triángulo rectángulo isósceles sus
ángulos son 90 45 y 45 y sabemos
entonces que estos dos catetos iguales
del triángulo isósceles miden raíz de 2
sobre 2 por la hipotenusa así es que
este lado mide raíz de 2 sobre 2 por la
hipotenusa y este lado también mide raíz
de 2 sobre 2 por ley
esos valores se obtienen directamente el
teorema de pitágoras digamos que este
lado mi idea y este lado también mi idea
entonces por teoría de pitágoras tenemos
que a cuadrada masa cuadrada tiene que
ser igual a h cuadrada
esto es 2a cuadrada es igual a h
cuadrada vamos a despejar a cuadrada al
cuadrado es igual a h cuadrada sobre 2
de donde a es igual a h sobre raíz de 2
lo cual es igual a raíz de 2 por h sobre
dos simplemente racionalice el
denominador aquí multiplicando por raíz
de dos sobre raíz de dos de ahí
obtuvimos estos valores entonces cuál es
el valor del área el área de un
triángulo es base por altura entre dos
así es que el área es entonces déjame
escribirla aquí abajo el área de este
triángulo
es igual a la base que es raíz de 2
sobre 2 por h por la altura que también
es raíz de 2 sobre 2 por h por un medio
por un medio sino multiplicamos por un
medio estaríamos obteniendo el área de
este rectángulo que tenemos aquí pero
nosotros queremos el área del triángulo
y esto es igual a raíz de 2 sobre 2 por
raíz de 2 sobre 2 esto es igual a un
medio multiplicado por un medio nos da
un cuarto de h cuadrada y se viene esto
a ver veamos raíz de 2 x raíz de dos es
2 sobre 4 es un medio x un medio si un
cuarto de h cuadrada ese es el área y
cuál va a ser el volumen de estas
rebanadas triangulares bien
el volumen el volumen de cada rebanada
triangular el volumen de estas rebanadas
va a ser igual al área de la cara
triangular que es un cuarto de h
cuadrada que multiplica al espesor en
este caso es de x de tal manera que si
integramos todos esos volúmenes desde
que x igual a cero hasta que x es igual
a c vamos a obtener el volumen de toda
la figura vamos a expresar eso entonces
básicamente para obtener el volumen de
toda esta figura vamos a calcularlo como
aquí para no confundirnos déjame
escribir que este es el volumen de la
sección transversal y aquí abajo si ya
voy a poner cómo calcular el volumen el
volumen de toda la figura de
la figura y esto va a ser igual a la
integral definida la integral definida
desde que x es igual a cero hasta que x
es igual hace del té x igual a cero
hasta x igual hace de un cuarto de h
cuadrada un cuarto de ya sabemos que hdx
es igual a efe x - x un cuarto de fx
menos gx todo eso elevado al cuadrado de
x de x y ya hemos concluido ya
encontramos una expresión una expresión
que contiene una integral definida para
ser más precisos que nos permite
calcular el volumen de esta extraña
figura que construimos aquí